hello and welcome to 30 playing and
super pula a1a not g6 is Bishop c4
probably not a good idea okay got the
Italian game oven okay I can also go to
six here's a song getting fashionable
ringing okay quite clearly this is a
playable line for white but yeah if
that's all there is Withey 45 then black
is immensely solid
yeah I try to play a little bit quicker
than usual look we're really ok so just
banging out some moves here ok so back
here probably mp5 something yeah I guess
it's still a good move i guess ok now
maybe b5 you know just to to stop any
night see for business ok yeah white has
absolutely nothing but it's difficult to
do anything with black as well okay
maybe I'm trying to put the night over
to f1
maybe d for now for white but no Jim the
Italian game is really quite unexcited I
get that rather often i even got it
quite often in my tournament games even
before it was before i became somewhat
fashionable on the top level gent that
ok for me here I thought he's got some
back rank problem so he cannot just take
with with pieces yeah and this 94th
actually almost possible I came night
before I can play tell look there it
looks kind of like this maybe some
tactic probably not but I'm okay with
this him okay I can go to d5 what would
you three and I think t5 I want to have
93 as well for those Forks
this one hmm ok what is the point
93 maybe it doesn't do that much a bit
maybe it's it's it's kind of slightly
annoying for him I have B 4 B 3 and so
on this is quick pawn Knight takes just
gives me the gives me that phone and now
okay before right it's not easy to stop
it's 92 and 94 is not possible okay here
i can take book checks check i also have
93 hand and 92
92 King everyone maybe just about
playable even though it looks rotten 93
m ok that was my original idea let's do
it
idea is to take on a phone next and then
be three
hmm yeah only has rookie three anywhere
it I wonder if I'm blundering stuff is
there something cool that I can do now
as usual I don't see it yeah I have a
couple of things that I could get a cool
night c5 rookie to okay that winsome
this way and threatening work takes the
2 and I don't see how he covers it
white resins and d4 was probably
untimely right yeah there was just i
plated in the simplest possible way but
black cannot be ver SI and this
pollution don't believe it so all this
looks normal Group D 1 and B 5 yeah I
don't think that this helped him that
much giving me this opportunity in the
first of the DeForest and working right
yeah yeah after this I'm better yeah yes
problem so you cannot play this oops
because of a half even this one because
check check with everything and that
makes it difficult and rookie one is
probably the best move button he took it
and now this is just a good position
okay 93 wow wow now I didn't see the
engines recommendation that or computer
just gives before with the clear
advantage or queen d7 with the CLE
advantage okay yeah this is a computer
and just takes it I just I just saw I'll
take but I didn't continue and he can't
go Queen d2 him I mean this isn't
totally clear but I didn't see that I'd
was the night I beep on is so dangerous
now can I was a mistake then but after
this I'm clearly better right I'm
winning at minus-3 computer finds no
defense against the beep on 93 this
distance so I played the best the best
line engine approves of all moves ok so
I'm happy I was decent
played I only made this is one mistake
overlooking here overlooking that that
resource hmm that's what's bad ok
interesting game though thanks for
watching